In an argument with someone about the wage gap.
Yeah.
They really believed that men and women work right next to each other doing the
same job.
And the woman is only making 75 cents to the guys dollar that's been put out
there in no time.
This is a crazy thing to argue.
Like if you're going to argue that you should know what that is,
you should know what that is.
Otherwise you're just talking shit like,
yeah,
which we all do sometimes.
But you gotta be willing to say,
I didn't really know which studies have you read.
And it's almost always zero studies.
I like to believe this versus whatever.
Luckily,
we're not in charge of making decisions.
People Love,
love to put these studies out.
Uh,
he like to tweet them out without having even looked at them at all.
Yeah,
it's,
some of these are there.
So there's studies out there that prove you everything.
Wage gap.
He was like,
so you're telling me I can get the same?
Look,
I'm a smart businessman who's made a bunch of money and I can get the same level
of talent out of this woman or better,
well let's just say equal,
but 75% or better,
sorry ma'am,
sorry,
or or equal or probably better,
uh,
95 cents on the dollar and I'm a smart businessman and I'm not going to go with
the lower costs,
equal talent,
better talent.
That's,
that's how can I run a successful business?
Making that kind of decision.
How can you,
yeah,
it would just,
they would be hired at far higher rights or you can look deeper at it and be
like,
oh,
it's just like total jobs or whatever it is.
Okay.
And I haven't raised studies,
but I just listened to people who've have,
I think you're right.
I think there's something to that.
If they're really could hire the same people for the same job and get a woman
who's just as good at it for 75 cents,
it's horse shit though.
They would all join it.
Hire only women.
The people don't know what we're talking about.
It's all based on what jobs you choose.
It's like,
it's not that men don't make more money because they do the same job and make
more money at that job and the woman does,
they do different jobs.
That's where the wage gap is.
The wage gap is in the number of hours that men work,
the different jobs that they choose,
what they excel in.
It's,
it has nothing to do with like two people that are both,
you know,
in the same line on a,
on an assembly line or something like that with the same amount of time and they
both make the same amount of money and one or rather the male makes a dollar a
dollar for every 75 cents.
That's not how the wage cap works.
It's just different jobs.
Okay.
So hearing that information,
like I remember when I first heard it,
it was like,
you can either go,
fuck you,
you're just trying to fucking shit on women or you can go,
Huh,
well let me,
I've never thought of that.
Let me look into that a little bit and then I'll get back to you instead of
immediately reacting.
Fuck off.
Well,
people get mad like that's not what it is.
Like,
yes,
it is what?
It is foolish if you keep arguing with
me because you don't even know what it is.
This is a dumb conversation now.
I can't argue with you when I know that you haven't read any of the stuff that
points to these numbers.
Like,
look,
the thing is no one should be like whatever you do,
whatever it is,
whether it is you make incredible sculptures or you build cars,
oh,
you're a painter.
Whatever the fuck it is that you do.
No one should be able to say that you doing this definitely should make as much
money as doing that.
No things are worth.
Yeah,
exactly.
Bowler.
Yeah.
At some point he was rights to,
I think top 15 in the world at his sport,
which is the equivalent of like a,
I'm trying to even think who would be like Carmelo Anthony and this Guy Tom and
dilutes at his sport made 38 grand and,
and fucking and,
and Carmela makes you know 20 million.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Your sports not as popular.
It's just not as popular way classes in his popular,
whatever.
Hell it works.
Yeah.
That's just how it was not fucking assault after.
I could see how you would want more money.
Yeah,
sure.
Everybody does.
I get that.
But like
there's certain people that they're just,
it's a harder do that job.
And the reason why they do it is because they know that it's more valuable.
So they work hard.
Definitely.
They get that job.
Imagine being the fucking CEO of a corporation.
How much pressure would be on you all the time being fucking Tim Cook over at
Apple.
Ah,
that's right.
I don't get paid as much as him.
Exactly like horrible.
Exactly.
Well that is the same.
This same philosophy is the reason why women approach now,
and I say some women I should say,
cause they're super hyper aggressive,
career oriented women that work as hard or harder than men may be even harder to
prove that there was tough as a man,
but they would take the approach that you and I would take.
They're like,
fuck that life mean I'm not doing that.
Whereas it's PR,
statistically more males push themselves by working longer and harder hours on
purpose to try to succeed.
It's just a natural thing.
They're trying to win a game.
There's a competition you have is putting points on the board.
By the time I serialism is fool's game to get into personally.
Yeah,
I see people doing that.
My friends from high school and I'm like,
you're wasting your life for what?
For a digit number.
You're not doing anything with yourself.
The problem is when they get stuck in this loop of obligation,
they get stuck in a loop of children and a mortgage and,
and then once you have a car and a nice house and you know,
you maybe want to get a boat dude,
you get stuck and you have all these payments and obligations and you're not
going to wear because you have a family.
Cause maybe you always wanted to be a rock and roll singer.
No.
And you never fucking got a chance to get out of the blocks and you're living
your life in this angry state,
unfulfilled,
angry state.
So the advice is for the young advices for young people,
the advices for people that look at their parents and all these other people
that are telling them what they have to do.
Are they right the other or is there a fucking path out there?
If you just figure out what you really liked to do and just only go that way
because if you go this way and then I'm to take a couple of years off and go
that way for a while and then I'm going to like,
I'm gonna to go back to school and get my degree just so I have something to
fall back on.
You just didn't,
you don't,
you didn't get any further down road.
You're on the same spot.
You would have been if he didn't do shit,
you gotta you gotta go forward.
But if you something forward,
even if it's the wrong direction,
is still getting experience doing something.
You're finding out what it takes to succeed and make the decision on purpose in
order to get something you think is right.
I don't know what it's like to think more and more people are saying no to this
old way of doing it and be like,
I want to be outdoors.
I value friendship over cash.
You know?
Things like that.
Experiences over fucking money and they're starting to go the other way.